[Music]
you say that again under arrest for the
murder of Rolla Legrand with the wrong
guy I was with her oh my mom let's go
this is a frame-up
hey pop you're right money get some
never escape without it we take a guy's
a millionaire last long keep me alive
I'll endure I can escape you can you
arrange something tells me you can be
quite savage
you are the property of the penal
administration of French Guiana there's
no way off snows away
I know many of you are thinking about a
state this is your best shipments feel
free to try whenever you like and come
with you there are two Guardians who are
always Beauty Bush what a best thing
that can happen to you is starvation or
you could choose to see what white
sharks are always if you manage to
survive your first attempt you'll get
two years in solitary second attempt
you'll get a life sentence at Devil's
Island
strange things happen there especially
2010 to help
if I ever get out I'm gonna a different
kind of life
[Music]
[Music]
you